the jurgen experience it's not just
journalists it's the journalists that
also consider themselves activists like
they're shaping culture and society with
their writing and musings and that
they're trying to push a narrative and
that you know ultra progressive woke
narrative
and they just they they won't stop with
it they won't indeed that i sent you
that thing jamie about uh the will smith
thing that's in the independent i sent
you a text message you showed it this
was hot yeah yeah jimmy dore sent this
to me and it's like what the
[ __ ] are you even saying here
it says white outrage about will smith's
slap is rooted in anti-blackness it's
inequality in plain sight
what and it's in the guardian it's kind
of depressing
they just get sucked into wokeness it's
just kind of like performative pearl
clutching hate no that was violence if
you think that violence is cool you need
to tell me where that line ends is it
just slapping can i kick someone in the
face if i don't like what they say like
where does that end you just knew that
this incident that was between two guys
also they happen to both be
african-american at some point there
would be articles
blaming white supremacy
they're like dude i'm almost impressed
by the leap of logic where you're going
like yeah dude that's awesome yeah it is
impressive that you're even going for it
well it took a solid 48 hours for
someone to concoct that like they had to
sit there you ever see that [ __ ] um
there's a meme of a woman there's all
these like calculations in the
background she's trying to like ponder
something that doesn't make sense
you've seen those that's them sitting
there i like trying to figure out how to
put this and make it white supremacy
it's inequality in plain sight what the
[ __ ] are you saying the the good thing
about this is that it's getting so
ridiculous now that i think
a lot of people who are just like
casuals casuals are starting to go like
all right we're starting to see a lot of
people's point that
this is sort of uh it's out of control
it's out of control wouldn't you love if
we had that guy on the podcast with us
please map this out for us yeah yeah
just you and me and that guy yeah i want
to see your astounding logic yeah it'd
be like all right all right now you're
gonna have to
use your imagination a little bit pearl
clutching here's how it is
pearl clutch it happened in america yeah
and there's racism in the history of
america it's rooted in racism yeah and
america was founded on racism yes so if
it happened in america and it's on
television which is racist racist yeah
yeah and the academy awards which is uh
academy oh so white yes right oscar's
also white yeah everything
that i always find the people who are
lying always say the most irrelevant
things and that's how you know they're
lying is it just a bunch of irrelevant
information around what's germane to
what happened
that's how i that's my [ __ ] detector
i'm going like you're speaking a lot
about a lot of
tangential irrelevant [ __ ] you're full
of [ __ ] well it's like one of those
charts where it's like you're trying to
get to the center the center is white
racism and you start off with here
black man slaps other black man over a
joke about a woman
you know misogyny is rooted in white
supremacy okay let's go to that
outrage is on television which is racist
and all it's all racist yeah somehow it
finds its way back to you can't hold
reliable yeah you can't let people just
go around slapping people
and
you just
you just this that is whether you think
it's violence or not it's violence it's
violence it's violence it was a it was
violence that happened on tv yeah it was
violent
um i think comedians should stop hosting
the oscars so they just tank because
it's the only redeemable quality about
that circle jerk yeah the only reason
why anyone tunes in is to hear ricky
gervais or whatever just yeah you know
bring it down to earth and have some fun
with it because otherwise we're just
sitting there
watching the most boring fake award show
where studios pay for those awards
did they really win it's a matter of
taste they don't even have a comedy
category go [ __ ] yourself yeah that's
basically giving a green light to the
pimp slap to what what will smith did
yeah to chris rock that is not a crime
to do to your wife in russia yeah chris
rock should have [ __ ] hit him back he
should have jumped on his back as soon
as he turned his back like that
that just filled him through an mma
brain 100 you just take us back you know
listen man here's the reality you don't
slap a man in the face and then turn
your back and walk away unless you
should have never slapped that man in
the first place
because you're only slapping a guy who
you know can't slap you back that's why
he slapped him yeah that's the only
reason why he slapped him and then
turned his back and walked away look if
he slapped him and then stood his ground
and waited for a return and was ready to
go to war that's one thing when you slap
a man you turn around and go back to
your seat
that is a sure sign you should not have
slapped that man yeah it's not fair i
just had this image of a movie like the
karate kid where chris rock just shows
up in austin he's like hey joe you know
betrayed me i was thinking to my friends
last night i was like imagine if chris
rock had just a year of solid jiu jitsu
training under his belt and as soon as
he took us back as soon as will smith
turns his back he just leaps
and takes his back and just squeezes
will out before the [ __ ] before the
security guards can get to him will
smith goes out wipes that smirk off will
smith's face listen apparently they
worked it out like uh i read that they
talked and will smith made a statement
and chris rock even apologized and
apparently they talked backstage and
worked it out which is the best i don't
think will smith should go to jail i
don't think any of that stuff should
happen i don't think they should take
away his academy award i think he knows
it was a foolish act everybody else
knows and i think it's one of those
learning experiences for the world it's
like a teachable moment right like the
whole world can see that we put stars
and celebrities up on pedestals but
they're just human beings and sometimes
human beings get pushed to the point
where they do something irrational right
and that's what he did he just did
something totally irrational that he's
completely embarrassed by right good